so today I'm gonna talk about modeling
search term revenue it's a problem
they've worked on on and off at system
one so I'm a data science at system one
it's an ad tech company located in
Venice so not too far so here's what
we're gonna talk about start with the
data science problem we're trying to
solve then we're going to move on to
techniques for handling categorical
variables in general then I'll talk
about the first solution that I had for
this problem that we're trying to solve
which involved mixed effects model then
moving into embedding layers and neural
networks and why this was a cool
solution for the problem we were doing
and maybe some conclusions from that
cool so here's the background on system
1 we bid on tens of millions of keywords
across multiple pay-per-click model or
marketplaces these keywords have been
organized in sort of an ad hoc fashion
they're grouped in different categories
some are semantic based so like you can
have like cars or health or you know
finance those kind of categories and
then some are based on like how much
keywords worth so we've some categories
are like these are high value keywords
and these are low value keywords so gets
a little tricky sometimes there's you
know a hundred thousand keywords in a
category sometimes there's a lot fewer
and then the sort of behavior of these
keywords is quite different some
keywords can spend up to a hundred
dollars a day sometimes a thousand
others only spend a few cents each month
or each week these keywords do exhibit
predictable seasonality but then there's
a whole swath of keywords that only get
traffic around specific holidays and
then there's a lot of keywords to just
kind of look like a random walk so it's
a it's sort of a tough problem to just
solve so this is just an idea of what it
looks like in terms of a number of
keywords and revenue percentage so you
can see we've got like some keywords you
know in the thousands of keywords that
spend hundred or a thousand dollars a
day then we've got like you know in the
hundreds of thousands of keywords that
can spend or get one click a day
basically and then there's millions of
keywords that get less than ten clicks a
month but as you can see it makes up a
significant portion of revenue
going to different you know ads or going
to different like websites around the
internet so it's important not to ignore
this piece as much as you do want to for
modeling purposes so also before we get
started just go through some definitions
because I'll probably mention these
quite a bit if you don't understand
something you can just stop me but so
like CPC is cost per click
that's how much we would spend on a
click there's revenue per click which is
you can think about how much revenue you
get from a conversion event so someone
like buys a pairs of sneakers that would
be a conversion and that would be how
much money that that actual conversion
is what event is worth then there's ad
clicks which is the clicks the number of
clicks that you pay for paid clicks
which think of his number of conversions
CTR 1 call it click-through rate 1 which
is your click-through rate on the ad
network that you're buying on so your
ads shown this many times and then like
1 to 10 percent of the time you'll
actually get a click on it CTR 2 is the
number of conversion events that you get
on your site over the number of sessions
that were driven from an ad click so
just some definitions so what we're
trying to do is like in most businesses
is maximize how much money you make
right so these are just two different
formulas or you know math problems of
using those metrics to figure out how
much money we're actually gonna make so
the first one is your impressions on an
ad network multiplied your by your
click-through rate on that ad network
then multiply that by how much money you
make for each click times your
conversion of CTR to your conversion
rate and subtract out the cost that you
paid for that conversion an impression
would be like every time your ads shown
somewhere on the internet yeah and then
the other way to look at this is you
know how much revenue you make times the
number of clicks you make or how much
revenue per click you make times number
of clicks and then subtract the number
of clicks that you paid for and how much
that cost an intuitive way to think of
this problem is the more you bid the
more impressions you're gonna get but
you're gonna pay more for those for
those clicks that drive traffic and the
lower you bid you're probably going to
be more profitable because you're
probably going to make a similar amount
for each
he's traffic that comes in but you might
not get very much traffic cool so why
have this talk I didn't want to bore you
guys with ad tech data but I found this
kind of interesting as this paper came
out in 2016 about using entity
embeddings to represent categorical
variables these guys used this to get
third place in the Rossman data set in a
capital competition and since then it's
it's pretty widely used technique and I
thought this talk was kind of cool
because you know I was able to apply it
to boring ad tech data and maybe make it
sort of interesting application in the
real world so starting with a little
background I want to talk about like
interpretability versus explained
ability so a models interpreter well you
can think of it as like a regression
problem where there's an intercept and a
slope and then compare that to a neural
network where you have different weights
and if you change a weight you have
literally no idea what's gonna happen to
the predictive variable so like some
more defined or clearly defined that
interpret ability is the extent to which
you can change the input variables and
predict and have a predictable change on
the output variable explained ability
which is kind of an interesting concept
is the ability to explain what's
happening inside a model so I'm using
this little picture over here which if
you look at the embeddings the word
embeddings for man women king and queen
if you subtract the vector man from
women and king from queen the cosine
distance between those two differences
is pretty similar so that's kind of a
way to embed the meaning of gender into
seemingly random vector of of numbers so
as data gets more complex it's really
hard to hold on to interpret ability so
sometimes depending upon your business
needs you can opt to choose for a model
that's a little bit more explainable
cool so now we've kind of set the
problem realizing we're dealing with
super high cardinality categorical
variables and so I want to take a minute
to talk about different techniques for
handling categorical variables in
general so to start they're pretty
difficult I wanted to use like date as
an example so if you have date as a
feature and you want to turn
this into a tabular data set like so not
a time series you can create basically
an infinite number of features from just
that one date feature you know because
as you know you categorical variable
does need to get turned into either an
integer or float to go into a machine
learning model there's just some
examples like you can use to kind of try
to capture seasonality in a tabular data
set so you can do like is month end day
since month end a cool trick is take
like sign day of week or cosign day a
week you can see in that bottom right I
don't know sorry if you can't see that
what that's looking like is the kind of
sine and cosine pattern so basically if
you take sine of the number 0 through 6
it'll put a it'll put like a Sunday near
Monday and Oh Tuesday near Wednesday
instead of just dummy coding them out so
that they're all independent entities
cool you can also turn them into other
categorical variables if you want like
and then dummy those out or perform some
other technique so just to go over so
this is like super simple example one of
the most common prevalent techniques
just one hot encoding or dummy coding
you can take each category within a
feature and then create its own feature
from that category and then the you know
that that cell is just gonna be a binary
like it is this feature or it's not this
feature this can blow up the features
place rather quickly but it's really
great for like regression based problems
so you can attach a slope to the
specific category and retain some of its
meaning so especially for like tree
based models targeting coding is a
really common technique that's used what
that basically does is it replaces the
categorical variable with the mean of
the target variable so this is done on
the training set you maintain a mapper
and then that's going to be applied to
the training set one where the the test
set one when data actually comes in so a
bunch of techniques to do this to reduce
overfitting you can use a blended
average which can wait based on counts
you can just add random noise leave one
out or k-fold
where you using subsections of the
actual data to compute the average and
then you can do something like smoothing
so you can set a prior in a posterior as
you're calculating these average
so here's what it looks like this is
just a straight average if you have high
cardinality categorical data like we're
talking about in the keyword space
you're gonna end up just memorizing the
last value and that's not necessarily
what you want to be doing because you'll
probably lose a lot of other cool
information so you can do leave one out
or K fold so you're just basically not
including the the observation that
you're looking at in the actual average
and just to note this is only done on
the training data this is to prevent
overfitting which when trying to you
know train either the splits or
coefficients that you're placing on
these things I want to take a minute to
mention kappa boost encoding just
because I like using this library they
have a cool way of doing it where they
reorder the data so they'll reorder the
categories and then they have this
concept of time so you have a prior and
then you as you add in observations
you're gonna update the average and then
you're gonna shuffle this and do this
few times than average that so that you
know creates a different value for for
what this is okay cool so that was one
way of handling categorical variables
we're gonna take a minute to talk about
mixed effects models cuz this was my
first approach to this problem and it
worked really well for a while and it's
it's a good approach to take in general
first thing about it is it's like
retains that interpretability you know
portion that we were talking about and a
mixed effects model is kind of the
parent of a linear model mixed effects
is composed of a fixed effect and a
random effect the fixed effects are
pretty much what we're familiar with in
terms of just least squares regression
it has a systematic and predictable
influence on the data and you can think
of this as like male versus female but
then random effects have non systematic
unpredictable influences on the data
this is where you're sort of repeatedly
sampling a person in a trial so each
person is going to behave differently
but that person may have its own pattern
within itself cool so there are a few
packages out there I just wanted to
mention I'm mainly familiar with gloom
net and LM before and then there's you
know some Python packages that work for
this there's a random forest
of this which I haven't used but I heard
it's pretty cool just wanted to mention
those and then rather than show the
actual data I thought I would just show
an example of what this actually does
and looks like so this is from the
documentation of the LME for package and
what this is is on your see this so on
your x-axis you have days of sleep
deprivation and then on your y-axis you
have reaction time and then each one of
these plots is an individual so this
individual is repeatedly sampled after
depriving them of sleep for a number of
days I'm not sure what their reaction
time is too but something so there's
three different models I'm showing here
so you have your redline so this is your
like complete pooling model and this is
just a regression on the entire data set
so the red line is the same for each one
of these individuals so sometimes it
looks good and sometimes it's a bad
model right then you have your blue line
the blue line is a subject level so this
is building a regression for every
single one of the individuals
individually and you're not sharing any
of the information from the from the
whole sample so I added these last three
data points so 370 to 373 and 374 to
basically show what this does when you
have really odd-looking data so that
blue line looks really bad for 372 you
would not want to include that in the
model it's probably you know and you
also only have limited data so there's
only two data points there on 373
there's only one data point so you
actually can't build a subject level
model from that you just have one
estimate so your Green Line is your
partial pooling this is where it borrows
say borrows a data information from the
whole sample and uses that to adjust the
slope and intercept from the individual
there's a lot of different ways to
specify how this works but as you can
see this is probably the best model for
the type of data that we're looking at
and it applied really well to this
keyword level model that that I
originally built so it has its ups and
downs this worked really great for a
while
works really well on high volume
keywords where you have a lot of data on
one keyword you can build a nice
regression line
can specify different distributions so
it doesn't necessarily have to have a
linear relationship and the output looks
good but as the number of keywords grew
as our business grew and the number of
longtail keywords also grew the model
will fail to converge not necessarily a
problem but would output a lot of the
same sort of naive means which doesn't
look good when it's been manually
inspected by individuals so not the best
model in terms of interpretability at
this point nor explain ability oh and
then like so another important
differentiation is that the models
relied on the fact that human had to
classify all these categories and these
categories were classified for the
business purpose not made for a model so
you know that actually is probably
detrimental to the overall accuracy cool
so enter embeddings this was the
solution to try and solve this problem
so one way to do categorical variables
in new neural net which does work well
is to just one hot and code everything
but we're dealing with actual keywords
here these key words do have meaning
they have semantic relationship to each
other and we sort of know heuristic aliy
that the the outcome variable is grouped
by category and it is grouped by
keywords that do mean similar things but
we don't know exactly how or when nor do
we have a mapping of where this keyword
should go
so other reasons not to do one hot
encoding is that the the more the the
higher the sparsity the more data you're
actually going to need to train this
model computation time increases
dramatically and furthermore it treats
all the words as independent entities so
they don't have relationships to one
another which which is what you're
looking for so there's been a lot of
good talks on embeddings today I think I
don't have ton of slides on it so this
is just one you know visualization of
how meaning is retained when you're when
you transpose you know these larger
vectors to a lower dimensional space
it's what an embedding is essentially
and you can see that like not only is
are things like male-female
relationships
maintained verb tense
country capital and there's a whole slew
of other so it's like there's a lot of
meaning that are in these seemingly
random vectors and hopefully we can use
that as a way to you know help with our
predictions tensorflow has got a cool
visualization you can just type in a
word and it'll show all the other words
that are kind of similar to it based on
the vector representation that you want
so I just thought I'd show that it's fun
to play around with on projector dot
tensorflow cool so basically here's been
my here was my approach there's 10
million keywords we have minimal data on
each keyword what we can do is we can
start by doing this trance translate
these into each keyword into a 50
dimensional vector we can use a pre
trained vector because people have you
know pre trained these things by the
location of words this you know next to
other words so we can borrow this so I
did this I pulled a glove vector and it
only had 40% of the words in the
database which is pretty good but not
enough to actually start this model
people search for you know some weird
terms sometimes that don't exactly show
up in a normal database so I had to do
something else so here's like a very
simple example of how you can use a
dummy model to set an embedding layer
for keywords that you probably haven't
seen before
so we do have a large database of
keywords because you know over time it's
grown so what I did is basically trained
a bigram model for every word in our
corpus so keyword think of it as like a
search queries there's multiple words in
that so you can just break that into
different diagrams and you're predicting
the next word so it's a dummy model you
train this model and then you can use
those embeddings for each of those
keywords and pull those out and
hopefully use those in a reasonable way
for you know predicting what you're
actually care about which is revenue per
click or cost per click something like
that all right so yeah this is just like
a little bit of sample code that's
pretty pretty blurry but this is I mean
think just like the PI torch you know
documentation page very simple by grand
model in training it's a pretty good
documentation there all right
so did we do anything right
like have we increased either
interpretability or explain ability we
definitely have not increased
interpreter ability so hopefully explain
abilities making sense at this point so
what I did is after due after training
this by grand model I did dimensionality
reduction on the vectors and then I just
sorted by the most extreme values and
the vectors to hopefully see if there
was some kind of grouping that was
naturally occurring so we can look at
the first dimension here and it looks
like some of these words actually belong
next to each other
you've got trade schools near me well
that one's a little funny but like cheap
motorhomes use conversion bans so
somehow some meanings actually getting
pulled out here and then in this other
dimension it looks like we more like
technology communication keywords and so
that's great because there's a ton of
different categories in this database
and we've pulled out seemingly two
categories that probably have some
relationship so just because they might
be grouped together semantically now
does that have any effect on the
predictive variable that we're looking
for so what I next did and hopefully
this makes sense let me know if it
doesn't I did dimensionality reduction
and then clustered the keywords and then
I plotted a density plot of the
dependent variable that we were going to
predict so here I'm just showing CTR -
and then RPC and you can see that the
density distributions just in these four
clusters is actually becoming quite
different so it looks like we are
starting to separate out the war it's
not just semantically but also by their
behavior in pay-per-click marketplaces
so that's cool
taking that one step further I did a
regression on the sort of human category
cuz categorical ization on the dependent
variable that we're predicting and then
also did on the same number of clusters
from the embeddings that i just made so
if you can kind of see this the
regression is basically showing for the
dependent variable that we're looking at
there's really not a significant
difference for most of the so these are
campaign ids it's like sorry that's not
the best thing to use but I thought it
would be anonymized and then so we're
showing that they're not you know
basically the campaign is not separating
the data by the dependent variable but
then you look at the
Buster's and we are seeing a lot of
significant differences so the more
clusters the better we're using 50
dimensions I think we can sort of begin
to come to some conclusion that there is
an explainable difference in the actual
values that we're trying to predict so I
felt pretty good about continuing on
with this model great so this is just
sort of like the bookkeeping and
actually doing this so sort of how this
worked is that you you build this model
then you pull out these weights and the
trick really is just to maintain a
mapping of your keyword to the weights
that you actually have you're gonna
convert the keywords into indexes and
then when you look up the embedding
layer that embedding layer index should
match the pre-trained embedding that you
just had and then that feeds into the
embedding layer for keywords in your
neural network model one other thing to
note is that when you train the model
and your first run through the data you
want to make sure you freeze the weights
on the embeddings because they're on the
key word embeddings because they're
already set to a decent place whereas
the other ones are initialized random
and they will need some training to get
to a decent spot so then you can
unfreeze the way it's lower than
learning rate and then retrain get your
final prediction cool and this is just
sample code I just threw this in here
because like the model is really simple
like it's just your sort of standard
linear layer model for like a PI torch
neural net and it's yeah you have your
categorical variables just looking up
the embedding layers the only one that
you're loading in first is your pre
trained one all the other ones are
initialized to random and then you're
gonna have some continuous variables as
well and then you're gonna predict your
outcome okay
so let's have a look see what that
actually looks like okay well here's
like we had a few choices we could have
just done general linear models we could
we use the mixed effects model it was
pretty good I haven't mentioned gbm's I
have some slides on gbm's they perform
really well and that was an option and
some of the categorical target encoding
techniques would have worked pretty well
for some of the really high cardinality
variables there and then we also have
neural nets which were chosen because
they helped out with the explained
ability
version of the model so you guys see
this okay that's a little blurry no well
I'll just explain what's going on okay
so on your so each one of these graphs
represents so there's this one on the
left this is a keyword the one on the
right that's also a keyword so there's
two different keywords that we're
predicting here on your x axis you have
bid so what I've done is predict the
value for the dependent variable which
is on the x-axis so like we have your
paid clicks on the top left we have your
ad clicks on the right there then
revenue per click and cost per click and
then you do that sort of profit equation
to get your profit curve which is which
is right there so what this is basically
showing is if you do a prediction for
each bid along this you know different
you know range of bids you can start to
get patterns that were what you would
expect so most of these graphs you want
to go up and to the left the more you
bid the more you pay theoretically it's
the more you're gonna make as well and
then so there's a trade-off between you
know how much you pay and then how much
you make and this forms this nice profit
curve the orange dots represent actual
data points so that's what it did
historically so you can see it's pretty
messy so it's really important to be
changing bids all the time
the size of the dot represents how far
back in the past this was and if
aggregated this up to the day so these
these graphs you know look noisy but
this is actually serves to make a pretty
good bid prediction for these
high-volume keywords so we know we can
use this model to set bids for the right
you know right position that can
accomplish the business goal we make
which is either to maintain a certain
amount of volume while understanding how
much money we might make or lose for
that matter or just try to find that
apex of the profit curve to set the bid
to make the highest amount of money but
what's cool about this is that we can
also output predictions where we've
never seen data for a keyword because of
these embedding layers that we have and
we can sort of communicate that these
predictions might actually be reasonable
because we've shared information already
from this embedding layer that used in
this neural net
and these graphs you know they look a
little funny but this they're not bad
they're going the right direction and if
you want to start trying out or testing
out a new keyword you can get an idea
not only how much volume it's gonna get
of how much it's gonna cost and
potentially how much is gonna make based
on the bid that you're setting so I
thought that was a cool sort of side
effect of building a model like this
yeah okay so start drawing some
conclusions here
so gbm's are also a good choice for this
I've used especially recently been using
you know gradient boosting with this
targeting coding technique and one hot
encoding it's been really successful if
you have super-high cardinality
sometimes you do have to get a little
more creative and try a solution like
this so one of the downfalls that I've
run into with trees is that when you
have that many categories if you're
using like h2o they have this concept of
like of the parameters called enum and
then there's a number of categories that
are allowed so each each split of the
tree they're gonna reshuffle the
categories based on the categories
within a feature based on the dependent
variables value but if you have too many
categories they're gonna start getting
arbitrarily lumped together so it ends
up happening is that occasionally you'll
get a really really bad prediction which
may give you the best over overall you
know lowest error rate but someone
inspecting the data are looking at a bid
maybe like you know why did you do this
this model might not be trusted so yeah
so they also do achieve these
state-of-the-art results and then you
know using a mixed effects model was
also an interesting choice because gbm's
don't really have a great way of
borrowing from a parent category
especially if you want to specify a
parent category there was that the you
know mixed effects random forest package
that you know could do something similar
to that but I was having trouble as time
grew on the glimmr models to converge on
these large data sets
training time went way up we were using
these massive machines to try to train
these models on CPUs so it wasn't
scaling as we liked another solution
which is interesting you know if you
want to break your data up and
different pieces is to actually do time
series for these these high volume key
words there is seasonality and to take
advantage of that in an explainable way
univariate time series are really great
for that so you could split it up and
try that but the data is way too sparse
if you want to have one model trying to
predict these key words cool so some of
the conclusions the choice of model I
thought should really support what's
most important to the business I think
some people have been talking about you
know how do you define success in a data
science project so you should really
start with that and then work backwards
to you know picking your tools and
picking what models you're gonna use so
that's why we ended up with this
embedding solution which is cool because
embeddings actually worked for this
we're not outputting bad you know
predictions on a daily basis and and
buyers are able to look at where your
bid is what you've predicted for each
one of the different variables and you
know inspect is this a reasonable thing
to do and for the most part it is
reasonable so you can trust the model
and then you can also show like oh it's
got the lowest root mean squared error
as well compared to the other stuff if
you really want to then the only thing
is interpretability and explained
ability do have business value it is
nice to be able to show people why
you're doing certain things or it's nice
to be able to say hey if you change this
this will happen so you can kind of
choose usually one or the other it's
where you get both and then you know the
lowest error rate does not always result
and the best results because of compute
time training consistency and then
manual validation it does need to kind
of pass the sniff test even if your
error rates pretty good sometimes
predicting zero on ad clicks is the best
prediction because most keywords don't
get ad clicks you really can't predict
that also you know other things keep in
mind it's like if you have a business
line that's losing money every machine
learning model is going to tell you just
to stop the business line that's also
not a acceptable answer from a machine
learning model so should keep in mind
the metric that your model is optimizing
is rarely the lever that it pulls nor is
that the metric your business is going
after so if you think about it this this
mod
we're trying to minimize root mean
squared error the lever that it's
actually pulling is changing a bid so
there's a relative change to a bid so
you can constrain that in a way so you
don't harm your business overnight and
then the metric that you're trying to
optimize usually profit but there's also
sort of a minimum volume component -
there's other things businesses will be
looking at so it's important to gather
all those requirements first you can
define that sort of math problem of okay
here the pieces we're predicting here's
the math problem do we need to constrain
this in any way and then you define your
data science problem here is the
interpretive all explainable solution
that I want to use and why and then you
can show your error metrics alongside
with those models to show that you've
actually made the right selection in
model choice you've trained it
appropriately and your predictions are
not only making sense to humans but also
you know making sense to machines do
cool and I think that's pretty much all
I have I have some pendeks slides but
yeah if you guys have any questions or
anything I could take those now um yeah
that was interesting can't go back to
the slide where you showed the graphs
this yep that one so you said like the
more we the more you bid the more profit
so that the line should be going upwards
- right what's happening in the bottom
graph oh yeah okay yeah it's good to
spend more time on this slide this one's
important and okay so the bottom slide
and I'm sorry you guys can't see this ya
should learn how to do this better so
this is you're right this is this is
profit right here so what that is is the
math problem of taking your revenue per
paid click times your CTR - then you're
subtracting your number of ad clicks -
your CTR one and you're forming this
graph right here ideally or a lot of the
times what this ends up looking like so
this this the x-axis goes pretty far
here but usually this is going to be U
shaped so right as you get to I don't
think this goes to zero but if it did go
to zero then your profits going to be
zero because you're not gonna get any
volume whatsoever if you have a
profitable business odds are as you
increase that
you're gonna start making money but not
as much because your volume is gonna be
low then there's gonna be a threshold
which is sort of your optimal point and
then it's gonna start diving because
you're now paying more you're paying
more for a clique than revenue that
you're gonna receive for a conversion
event so having it kind of go up and
then shoot straight down basically to
like infinite losses I think what you
should expect from like the profit
version of the curve but the other ones
that you're looking at should basically
all go up into the left at least for
these metrics that we're looking at here
I think you this is very interesting are
you publishing your slides anywhere so
we can refer to them oh yeah I can I can
post one LinkedIn or something like that
cool so one of the nice things about
using you know neural nets is that you
could potentially jointly train on
multiple outcomes have you experimented
with jointly dreaming against your
conversion rates and your revenue oh
that's a good idea
I have not experimented with that that
sounds cool yeah the question that I had
is more related to the metrics like was
there any particular reason why you
selected those metrics why you didn't go
with other ones oh yeah that's a good
question
like right cuz you could just model like
you could model profit directly right
you just be like how much money am I
making so let's let's just put this as
the dependent variable build one model
and go from there and then also there
was multiple there's the other where's
the other or the equations some
beginning
there we go so then there's this other
one impression CTR 1 and CTR 2 right so
those are conversion rates and you can
think of that as more of a logistic
regression did they click or did they
not click which is interesting I
actually the reason actually I chose the
second one for this is I have done the
first one before - and clicks
conversions are kind of interesting
because they can exceed you can exceed
convert you can have two conversion
events on one click which kind of like
if you're going for a mixed effects
model and you want to specify a certain
distribution you can run into a few
constraint problems on
you know using a logistic regression or
binomial distribution for your outcome
and it got a little bit messy and
there's some predictions where you'll
have conversion events like 10 times
conversion it's but like you think about
like Amazon you're trying to measure you
have a you buy an ad click that goes to
Amazon site and then someone buys you
know 15 different things after that you
want to attribute that back to that
first ad click um in terms of a you know
15 thousand percent conversion rate it
gets a little odd in your data set and
but you don't want to throw it out
either because it's a super important
event and if you have keywords that are
only getting you know one click a month
but their conversion rate could be that
high so think about it once per year
they'll have a fifteen thousand percent
conversion rate and then you know the
other eleven months they just go over
one you don't want to like kill bidding
for that necessarily so that's kind of
the only reason it's just the way the
data was behaving kind of influence the
choices that I was making for that but
yeah you could do a lot of other stuff
oh and the other thing I want to say is
the I like the explain ability of being
able to pull it in two different pieces
some of the cool side effects about this
is some people only care how much key
word costs to buy or they only cares
like on my site traffic coming in from
this category how much money could it
possibly be worth so the side effects of
this model is you can pull out the
pieces and then distribute that for
other decision making so sometimes thing
about side effects are cool you do okay
thank you much
[Applause]